there are lots of internationally
successful equestrians Thomas vineberg
for instance one silver at european
championships in Prague but not many of
them started their own companies at the
age of 19 the way he did hello my name
is Thomas Bach hello I'm Tamas vine bag
I'm 27 years old this is gigolo John I'm
here on my land and often where I coach
riders and work with horses I'm a
showjumper myself and today I'd like to
show you a few places in often you might
not know about Elijah Sh Kennedy
Weinberg grew up with equestrian sports
his parents were also successful show
jumpers and coaches and he followed in
their footsteps he buys young horses
trains them presents them at
competitions and sells them Feinberg's
first recommendation is Atkins
equestrian stadium it seats some 40,000
spectators and it's one of the largest
horse riding venues in the world each
year it hosts the CH io or conquer a
peak international official featuring
Four Nations Cup events
that's his permission damn for me this
is the most important and most beautiful
place in the world it's the world stage
of equestrian sport once a year the
showjumping elite media to compete the
audience in oven is amazing I have no
public on its absolute kivati atmosphere
is like nowhere else no one everyone
should experience this at least once so
tiara I'm Molly lived hum the CH io is
one of the world's oldest and most
renowned tournaments more than 500
horses 300 riders and 350 thousand
spectators take part it's a great show
and great sport for his second tip we
plunge into auctions history we enter
the city centre through the front gate
he is in fluid hakuna Gaddafi Kings used
to go through this gate to their
coronations in the market square dacia
but this was the entrance to Athens
outer city wall nowadays it's the
entrance to paunch straße where you can
find lots of pubs and restaurants and
other interesting places under shown
into the Santa not offended
whether at noon or at night students or
business people everyone meets on
polchasa the university is around the
corner prices in the bars and
restaurants are moderate and the people
of Aachen are very cosmopolitan the
sharra unhappiness the charm of Aachen
is simply that because the border is
nearby there are lots of international
visitors no ordinary German city can
match Athens flare
now border is the crucial word the third
recommendation is outside the city
limits you can take a long walk or drive
there he hasn't been only we're in the
Netherlands here we're Belgium and now
I'm in Germany yes since agenda Oakland
the tri Pointe in the tri-border area is
a popular day trip destination and
always good for a snapshot here the
borders of the Netherlands Belgium and
Germany meet and you can experience the
European Union's open borders firsthand
any one of the restaurants in the
tri-border area is the perfect place to
drink to that he has my ads we've come
to the end of our trip for today I'm
sitting in the Netherlands with my
belgian beer yeah and there's a
beautiful view of our configuration at
athens in